des bouleversé vous voyez j'ai pas
pleurer comme ça depuis la mort de mon
mari
c'est le choc pour les rambolitains
après le meurtre de la fonctionnaire de
police stéphanie qui a été tué vendredi
23 avril à l'entrée du commissariat de
rambouillet où elle travaillait de
nombreux habitants sont venus lui rendre
hommage en déposant des fleurs devant
l'hôtel de police
touchés ils soutiennent cette famille
endeuillée pourquoi on méritait pas cela
personne ne mérite ça moi j'ai deux
filles et aussi mon ami aussi faim deux
orphelins c'est terrible c'est terrible
elle faisait que son boulot je veux
donner mon soutien aux policiers je
trouve qu'ils sont bien mal traités
c'est horrible mais ça va changer parce
que cette femme encore une fois n'était
pas n'importe qui on est tous touchés
c'est atterrante de penser à cette mère
de famille qui est parti vendredi matin
qui a quitté son domicile qui a dû
embrasser ses filles et qu'il reviendra
pas stéphanie avait 49 ans et vivait
avec son mari et ses deux filles dans le
village de saint léger en yvelines
à quelques kilomètres de rambouillet une
ville paisible selon ses habitants c'est
vachement call c'est pas du tout elles
seront pensés mais ça peut arriver
n'importe où mais bon c'est quand même
assez touchant bas ici en bouillie oui
c'est arrivé c'est la première fois je
vous dis les gens qui prennent pas un
gérant bolton le compagnie pour les
yvelines et plus particulièrement la
police sont une nouvelle fois endeuillée
après le couple de policiers assassinés
à magnanville en 2016